[Musique]
et c'est avec vous Grégory canalé
bonsoir bonsoir Mathilde hier Gérald
haranin le ministre de l'Intérieur a
annoncé qu'il y avait eu 1040 actes
antisémites commis en France depuis le
début de la guerre entre Israël et le
Hamas quelle est la situation dans les
Yveline greégoryi les répercussions du
conflit se ressentent également dans le
département pas de chiffres néanmoins à
vous donner la préfecture des ivelines
ne souhaite pas communiquer sur le sujet
de son côté l'association juif de morpa
et ses environs que nous avons contacté
continue de recenser des actes
antisémites mais ne constate aucune
hausse particulière dans les Yvelines en
revanche l'association confie une
inquiétude et un sentiment d'insécurité
de plus en plus important et parmi les
victimes de ces actes antisémites l'
villinoise yilbron Pivet la présidente
de l'Assemblée nationale a porté plainte
après la réception d'un nouveau courrier
antisémite adressé à sa permanence de la
5e circonscription interrogé par nos
confrère du Parisien son entourage
indique qu'elle aurait déjà reçu une
vingtaine qu'elle aurait déjà déposé une
vingtaine de plaintes à ce sujet cette
année et les agressions à l'encontre des
élus persistent dans le département
puisque Carl OL a lui aussi déposé
plainte la semaine dernière le député
renaissance de la 12e circonscription a
également déposé plainte à la suite de
menace de mort proféré à son encontre
sur le réseau social x ex Twitter et
dans des posts publiés par des comptes
anonymes le parlementaire est représenté
face à un individu du armé d'un couteau
ou encore dans un sac plastique au
milieu d'un cimetière après une
interpellation jeudi l'affaire a été
classée sans suite vendredi un jour un
de nous y passera a tweetter l'ancien
maire de poissie toujours sur le réseau
social X et à Guill en courour le Golf
National de Saint-Quentin en Yveline a
une nouvelle fois été saccagé il a été
pris pour cible ce site olympique par
des activistes dans la nuit de vendredi
à samedi une partie du Green du trou
numéro 8 a été ravagé par des coups de
pioche le rendant impraticable
les dégâts s'élèvent à près de 2000 €
des inscriptions ont aussi été
retrouvées sur le parcours parmi elles
je cite 220 km Carr pour les golfs et 0
km Carr pour la biodiversité ou encore
ils construisent des golfs nous voulons
des forêts fin de citation en 2022 le
golf national avait déjà été visé par
une action du groupe extinction
rebellion et contacté par notre
rédaction le directeur du site Philippe
Pilato n'a pas souhaité commenter ses
actes et bien merci beaucoup Grégory
Canel pour toutes ces informations et
comme d'habitude si vous aussi vous
voyez une information ou une image près
de chez vous qui vous a marqué n'hésitez
pas à nous la communiquer sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
7we news